many many months ago there was a leak
about not only a Thunderbolts movie
coming to the MCU but a Thunderbolts
trilogy and it seems like yesterday the
first signs of that happening have been
revealed how's it going everybody it's
Warren and it seems like the
Thunderbolts are heading to the MCU
yesterday I did a video about William
Hurt the actor who plays Thunderbolt
Ross and the MCU being on set of the
Black Widow film now the Black Widow
film has officially wrapped up they had
their wrap party so it's a little odd
that he was there after the wrap party
but speculation is that he is filming a
post-credits scene for the movie now in
these leaked photos he looks very
different than he does from Civil War
and in Avengers infinity war and in my
video yesterday I talked about how this
could be evidence of Red Hulk coming to
the MCU we looked at the photos and
talked about what was sort of going on
with Thunderbolt Ross and these photos
but in this video we got to talk about
why is he there and right now one of the
most logical answers is he is there to
recruit somebody for the Thunderbolts so
let's break it all down quick reminder
to subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date with the MCU and so you can enter
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 so as I
mentioned right now everybody is asking
the question why is Thunderbolt Ross
appearing on the set of black widow for
a post-credits scene especially because
in Avengers in game and spoiler alert
here black widow dies so what is he
doing and who is he talking to well the
big theory going around right now is
that this scene appears to be
Thunderbolt Ross recruiting somebody for
the Thunderbolts there is a red Hulk's
version of the Thunderbolts and of
course Thunderbolt Ross is Red Hulk and
considering the fact that this is
probably the post-credits scene for
Black Widow there are two options
taskmaster or Elena Bulova now Jelena
Bulova is Black Widow sister and could
most likely go on to be the new Black
Widow and the MCU the theory going
around right now is that somehow elena
and natasha romanoff the original black
widow in the MCU escaped their old life
with the help of hawkeye but instead of
Yelena getting a deal like Black Widow
Yelena has to spend some time in prison
first
so Thunderbolt Ross come in to recruit
Ile in a Bulova could be somewhat of a
Suicide Squad type of deal just like
Nick Fury recruited Avengers for the
Avengers initiative Thunderbolt
Ross could be recruiting people for the
thunderbolts and this is a way that
Jelena could earn her freedom by joining
the thunderbolts and then of course
another option is taskmaster who could
easily be recruited for the thunderbolts
as well
taskmaster is a villain who is very
well-liked in the fandom and marvel most
likely won't kill him off right away now
another option that goes back to a leak
that was put out many many months ago is
Baron Zemo so way before avengers
endgame came out there was a twitter
account by the name of Roger Waddell and
this account ended up leaking a ton
about Avengers in-game way before it
came out and it all ended up being true
and back in last December Roger Wardell
tweeted something out about the
Thunderbolts and about Baron Zemo his
tweet said don't worry
Marvel still has big plans for Zemo
ghosts Justin Hammer general Ross and
the abomination the leader is being
discussed to return as the main villain
of the Thunderbolts which is being
planned as a trilogy and again Roger
Waddell was accurate about every leak
that he put out for Avengers in game and
we have already seen the return of Baron
Zemo it has been confirmed that he is
returning in the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series so could these people
that he listed in this tweet be a part
of the Thunderbolts that are coming to
the MCU a-10 thunderbolt Ross's Red Hulk
Jelena Bulova as the new Black Widow and
taskmaster and that's a heck of a
Thunderbolts team a team that a lot of
people could probably get really excited
about a new Black Widow taskmaster the
Red Hulk Justin Hammer abomination ghost
and Baron Zemo
this could quite possibly be our
Thunderbolts lineup what do you think
about this can you get behind this
lineup for the Thunderbolts and what do
you think Thunderbolt Ross is doing on
the set of Black Widow I personally
think that the Thunderbolts initiative
is starting right here on the set of
Black Widow in the post-credits scene
but let me know what you all think and
if you had your choice what would your
lineup for the Thunderbolts be be sure
to let me know in the comments below
also give the video a like if you
enjoyed it and be sure to subscribe to
my channel so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to them see you and
so you can enter for your chance to win
an Xbox one or a ps4 I'll be picking a
giveaway winner when I hit five hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers also if
you'd like a chance to win a Nintendo
switch you can follow me on Twitter and
click the link in the description down
below as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof